i wanna i wanna bring up this story just
because it's it's in the realm of
canceled culture and it's hilarious so
we have this once again from bounding
into comics pro tekken player tanakana
dropped from esports team after saying
short men don't have human rights
saying um men under 170 centimeters in
height don't deserve human rights
according to a report from japanese news
outlet jaycast during a stream on
february 15th tanakana declared that men
who are under 170 centimeters just over
five foot five don't have human rights
adding they should have bone lengthening
surgery to compensate for their lack of
height
i uh i do think there are a lot of
people who are deeply offended by that
but uh i think it's it's i hope she's
joking because if it is it's actually a
funny joke
but i but now she's canceled before
saying it right as a five foot five
individual i'd like just like to say
that i'm extremely offended by this and
i think that her cancellation is exactly
uh she got exactly what she deserved uh
and i am not getting bone lengthening
surgery unless the government offers to
pay for it so as a six-four individual i
do not identify with your your problems
you can't understand my lived experience
that's the problem yes yeah my height
privilege you're you're an oppressor
yeah don't you understand oh yeah and
you're oppressing yes see i don't know
when i'm going to finally get my do in
the social hierarchy of identity
politics but i think being short means
i'm not at the exact bottom as a
straight white male but i'm getting a
little bit closer to the top by being
under five six now i will say
i think the issue is she was kind of
joking but in a more serious way like
it's one thing if the point of the joke
is that you're mocking like there's the
stories about tinder where if a guy's
list his height is under six feet they
never get response responses if you're
mocking those people by saying it and we
know you're mocking the idea it's a
funny joke but if she's actually saying
like
jokingly she does think they deserve
human rights but she's insulting about
it that's kind of a dick move you know
what i mean was she like streaming and
she just said it to the her followers
while she was streaming because i could
see like if you're just gaming and
you're like oh yeah i hate these people
they should all you know what like just
joking like it just comes out as like a
goofy little kid thing but
i don't know she's basically saying that
a guy went to deliver her food and he
like muttered and mumbled in front of
her house rang the doorbell then asked
her for her number and she said you know
she was scared because he knows where i
live so it's tough i don't want them to
start a fire or something and by acting
coldly he was short maybe only 165
centimeters she continued if he was tall
and muscular i might have given him my
contact information isn't that amazing a
rough life man yeah she wasn't insulted
by being hit on she was insulted by
being hit on by a short guy exactly now
imagine if it was a guy on stream no no
no mind you she's gotten the boot right
so hey at least there's some consistency
there because i would say if there was a
dude and he was saying that like a woman
delivered his food and she was morbidly
obese and you know she asked him for his
in his number and he was like oh get out
of here yeah he'd be banned instantly
they'd be like you're fat shaming and
all that stuff i actually think it's
funny i wouldn't have expected her to
get any penalty for mocking short dudes
like that i'm actually surprised this is
a story at all yeah
that she got booted off her team yeah
i'm i'm surprised that anybody cared
really i mean getting she's probably
getting kicked off a team i mean she
probably had a very expensive salary
that they needed to get rid of that's
true they found their reason they're
like short guys really is that really a
reason to get rid of her like it'll
happen hold on this is the secret that
people need to understand when we often
hear about cancellations what we're
really hearing about is a company trying
to break a contract that they can't
break exactly but they have morality
clauses saying if you shock or offend we
can terminate your contract immediately
and this is what you get so people
people might be like oh why why was gina
carano fired maybe it really had nothing
to do with it maybe they were just like
we're paying her too much and we just
don't like her
we need an excuse for termination well
it probably was ideological lines if
they wanted to get rid of her this just
gave them the excuse and it's
selectively enforced because pedro
pascal said stuff that was way worse
uh and he's of course he's part of the
in-group so he's allowed to to exist in
that sphere but they're like we need a
reason that guy's creepy
the things he's he's posted and tweeted
about he's like a creepy guy i i
wouldn't have posted anything that any
one of them have posted but but the
truth is like
i i kind of am a first amendment
absolutist right and so i i i think just
far away right but i also have thicker
skin than most people and so you know
i'm not offended by it uh i i think i
think in the case of jeff silker and and
certainly maybe in this case of this
tekken uh player i think this is a money
thing i also like that it's a tekken
player yeah she's
saying she's part of a japanese team is
that part of the story i think that was
mentioned that she's i know she says she
was japanese
um if that's the case maybe there's a
cultural thing about hating on short
guys because i think japanese people
might be generally
nothing like nothing in life is worse
than disingenuous morality that is the
worst thing in the whole universe you
know i i
i think
there's a there's a big divide when we
talk about the multicultural democracy
the constitutional republic i think a
core element of it is strength through
hardship strong men weak men or women or
whatever and you know
you've got a lot of soft people that
can't handle the real world they can't
they
it's
they're so dependent maybe it's
independent versus codependent is
another way to look at it for me i'm
kind of like you know if i was working
in an industry in fact this literally
happened and they were doing things i
didn't like i'd be like i won't do it
you know when i worked for fusion
they they hire me on and they say we're
going to be nice vice we want to be edgy
on the ground do reporting but we're not
going to be as crass and crude and over
with like sex drugs and rock and roll
and i'm like yeah i totally get it like
we can get that that that on the ground
adventurous vibe that like cool hip
feeling you know whatever trying to get
while still being family friendly i'm
down and then six months later they're
like we decided we're gonna be woke and
i said okay well i'm not you know i'm
going to keep doing my thing and they
were like then you can you know i tried
quitting they offered me more money and
then ultimately i'm like dude i'm not
going to do it i don't care about you i
don't care about your company i would
much rather sit in my living room
playing video games and fall asleep than
deal with whatever it is you think you
can offer me so maybe that's just like
anti-social whatever i don't i don't i
don't rely on on them for
my confidence or my self-esteem
but i think a big difference between you
know the two overarching political
factions are people who are desperate
for recognition and desperate for um you
know people to they they want people to
to think good things about them and then
there are people who are just like yeah
i literally don't care what you think
i'm gonna live my life and be true to
myself you know seven i was doing
hollywood acting and youtube and i
started to get i was like what you were
saying i was seeking the attention i
wanted i was like when i went on oscar
i'm gonna thank my geometry teacher from
10th grade i was really excited in my
whole life and then i started doing
youtube videos and i started getting the
attention elsewhere and i realized okay
it's not all about the attention it's
why are you getting the attention what
are you contributing and that really
changed my perspective on everything
after that i left that industry pretty
much i i want to change that industry
you know
well
you build out of nashville and you
create your own
it's it's unchangeable it it's it's it's
sodom and gomorrah at this point right
it's it's it's it's gone they think new
york i think that's how hollywood got
started they fled the mob because the
mob was trying to shut them down in new
york all these directors
1910 20s
i'm really inspired by the tool song you
know uh uh just you know uh enemas like
you know learn to swim yeah push it all
the way it will wind up in the back
favorite it was arizona bay baby i was
just thinking that praying for mayhem
praying for tidal waves in california
the federal government was struggled to
enforce tax law
so it was a lot cheaper and easier to uh
but i'll give you an example ian you
know when people say they want to change
the system it's like you're walking up
to the the sears tower in chicago i know
it's called the willis tower we're from
chicago
and you're saying i want this building
to be my building by all means you can
accomplish that with great power and
time and dedication but that's like
trying to move a monolith that's such a
great structure build a new building
start your own building and so this is
the way i see it why should i go to
austin everyone's like we're going to go
to austin and i'm like it's woke central
why would i want to go to austin no
we're going to get a field in the middle
of nowhere in west virginia and we're
going to build our own building and
we're going to build our own thing out
here because i'm you know there's also
people going to nashville i certainly
think nashville is a way better bet than
austin but even then i look at it and
i'm just like i'd be really happy just
having my own little free damastan that
we can start up and we can build on our
own because i'm not dependent upon
anyone else for what we seek to create
and that's and that's and that's the
that's the plan man yeah there has to be
a a happy medium between infrastructure
right uh and and uh freedom right and
the ability to to sort of do what you
need so nashville dallas a couple of
these other cities are are great places
for that because you can you have enough
sort of talented people who can help you
fight the culture but remember someone
has to handle the instagram account and
someone's got to handle the marketing
and someone's got to cut the trailer and
you got to be close enough to an airport
yeah otherwise i'd be in north northern
maine yeah or wyoming but uh legit we
did look at properties in uh rural
pennsylvania maine
montana wyoming and the big problem with
all of it is they actually have really
great internet no joke airports
and so it's like how do we actually
bring people out to the middle of
nowhere well it's really difficult but
yeah with west virginia you're close
enough to dc about an hour right so the
airport's right there so that's
something you know that ends up working
out
i guess we got to build an airstrip and
a sound stage
the 500 million dollar sound stage in
the in the airport and then we're set
yeah good perfect the airstrike on top
of the sound stage is that what it was
helicopter helicopter pad on top of the
sound stage we got to start investing
helicopters
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time